tiene muchas posibilidades
para futuras aplicaciones en la arquitectura.
Aquí se ve una casa
para un desarrollador en China,
que es una caja de vidrio de cuatro pisos.
Todavía es una de caja vidrio porque queremos acceso visual,
pero ahora está forrada con esta capa termobimetal,
es una pantalla que la rodea, y esa capa puede en realidad
abrirse y cerrarse según el movimiento del sol en la superficie.
Además de eso, también puede detectar áreas privadas
para que puedan diferenciarse de las zonas públicas
del mismo espacio a distintas horas del día.
Esto quiere decir básicamente que, en las casas de ahora,
ya no necesitemos cortinas, persianas ni celosías
porque es posible cubrir el edificio con estas cosas,
así como controlar la cantidad de aire acondicionado necesario en el edificio.
También estoy tratando de desarrollar algunos componentes de construcción para el mercado.
Aquí ven un típico panel de ventanas
de vidrio doble, y en ese panel,
entre las dos piezas de vidrio, el doble acristalamiento,
estoy tratando de hacer
un sistema termobimetal
para que cuando el sol golpee la capa exterior
y caliente la cavidad interior, el termobimetal
comience a curvarse, y lo que realmente va a pasar
es que empezará a bloquear el sol
en ciertas áreas del edificio,
o en todas, si es necesario.
Imaginen que eso se aplicara incluso
en un edificio alto donde los sistemas de paneles
van de una planta a otra hasta 30 o 40 pisos, toda la superficie
podría variar en diferentes momentos del día
dependiendo del reflejo del sol en la superficie.
Estos son algunos proyectos futuros en los que estoy trabajando
que están en los recuadros, donde se puede ver,
en la parte inferior derecha, en rojo, que son en verdad
pequeñas piezas de metal térmico, que
tratamos de hacer mover como cilios o pestañas.
Este último proyecto también es de componentes.
La inspiración —y si han notado, una de mis áreas
de influencia es la biología— proviene del saltamontes.
Los saltamontes tienen un sistema respiratorio diferente.
Respiran a través de unos orificios en los costados llamados espiráculos,
y llevan el aire que pasa a través de su cuerpo para enfriarlos.
En este proyecto, trato de ver cómo podemos
considerar eso también en la arquitectura, cómo llevar aire
a través de los agujeros en las paredes de un edificio.
Aquí pueden ver algunos de los primeros estudios de bloques
por donde efectivamente pasan los agujeros.
Esto es antes de instalar el bimetal térmico,
y esto es después de instalarlo. Disculpen,
es un poco difícil de ver, pero en la superficie, se pueden observar las flechas rojas.
A la izquierda, se ve cuando hace frío y el bimetal térmico
es plano para que impida al aire pasar a través del bloque,
y a la derecha, el bimetal térmico se curva
y permite que el aire pase. Estos son dos componentes distintos
en los que estoy trabajando, y de nuevo,
es algo completamente diferente porque pueden imaginar
que el aire pudiera potencialmente pasar a través de las paredes
en lugar de abrir las ventanas.
Quiero dejarlos con una última impresión sobre
el proyecto, o este tipo de trabajo y el uso de materiales inteligentes.
Cuando están cansados de abrir y cerrar las persianas
todos los días, cuando están de vacaciones
y no hay nadie los fines de semana que encienda y apague los aparatos,
o cuando hay un apagón
y se quedan sin electricidad, estos bimetales térmicos
seguirán trabajando sin descanso, de manera eficiente
y para siempre. Gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)